hey everyone it's my photos and welcome
to the order flows market analysis for
the week of January 12 2018 and again I
apologize I haven't posted a video for
about a month already I just you know I
usually I take off the last couple weeks
on the first week of January the last
couple weeks of December first week of
January you know to just you know that's
that's the holidays it's the time to
spend with your family and you know
generally the markets are slow anyway
the last couple of weeks and the first
away with with our new president it's
been great for the markets a lot of
volatility a lot of great trading
opportunities so I'm getting back in the
swing of things and I hope you start
getting videos out on a fairly
consistent basis one or two a day
hopefully that's my goal
no promises and you know just another
big change is I've really jumped in to
since December really jumped into
NinjaTrader eight you know I've been a
very slow adapter but you know I'm
really enjoying it it's it seems you
know the latest version is very stable
the order flows trader does run on
ninjatrader 8 we have a version for it
and many of my indicators do I mean the
newest one that I have the SNR levels
which I'm going to show you later you
know which is it's just killing it it's
just killing it a lot of great results
people have been telling me about so
just a brief disclaimer this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or making in
their type of investment decision
futures trading contain substantial risk
and it's not for every investor and
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that can be lost
without jeopardizing one's financial
security or lifestyle only risk capital
should be used for trading and only
those were sufficient risk capital
should consider training past
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results
well tools I use in this presentation
are the order closed trainer and the
Balto's SNR levels and I'll be using the
ninja trader 8 pretty much going forward
now on majority of almost all my videos
so you know and I know some people are a
lot of people actually are still on
ninjatrader 7 and that's fine you know
we still support it I do I do run ninja
trader 7 on a different PC and I still
use it for testing purposes as well but
really the the move forward with ninja
trader is ninja trader hate
I'm scheduled to do a webinar believe it
sound Thursday January 25th with
NinjaTrader so you know and I really
think one of the reasons why they
finally finally acquiesced and and
biting me on is because I told him using
NinjaTrader eight so you know because I
know NinjaTrader it's really making a
push making that push as well
NinjaTrader is for people to use NT 8 so
this is NinjaTrader this is a chart for
NinjaTrader 8 and it's it's quite nice
you know I like my template that I
finally it took me a really a while this
sort of settle on it the font size I
mean you could you could play around
right I use different fonts on different
charts like you know sometimes you want
it bigger but honestly I'm fine with
this on the screen alright this is on a
27-inch screen that I use probably you
know I'm in the process of doing a major
move my family from Asia to the US this
year so you know I've I've been wanting
to buy more screens but I don't want to
buy them and I have to ship them over to
the US I'd rather just buy them in the
US so and I'm hoping to build up about
get four screens one for each market as
opposed to just sort of tabbing back and
forth I mean you can do that if you like
you know there's nothing wrong with it
but you know me I'm the type of person I
like to see everything on the screen and
just you know visual a visual person you
know it's like looking at Instagram yeah
you always just want to look then look
on the next thing look on the next thing
look on the next thing anyway I'm
babbling on so let's take a look at S&P
yesterday and it's very crazy market
these last this it's the beginning of
the year actually usually first week of
January it's a little bit slow first two
trading days then things just shortages
back to normal or the reason I say it's
a bit slow is because you know Japan in
Japan is usually off like the second
trading day of the year so it just sort
of makes it a little bit quiet but
anyway Oh another time ok so yesterday
right we got this big run-up right so
you have this low area here on the 2770
it's right around the cache
open here and we started moving up
moving up moving up yeah you've got a
ratio on a divergence here you know
right after the cash open this is a
beautiful move the quick quick move up
basically over the next 30 minutes but
the one that I wanted to talk about
there really stuck out I mean this is
the beauty of order flow if you
understand order flow and you know what
to look for right I have these ratios
this is the hallmark of the overflows
trader right when I created the order
closed trader I wanted to take the
volume footprint chart to the different
to the next level and help do some of
the analysis that I was doing and one of
the things was the ratios to find
support of buying in a bar or price
rejection in a bar but this one here at
9:35 very bullish I mean just looking at
this bar you can see at 6:09 here you
know 636 so imagine your market is
moving up moving up got some steel runs
into an area here I mean there's some
strong volume here strong offers 2,100
1,400 1,300 and the market comes off it
comes off to here in this bar okay in
this bar you've got very supportive mine
you got the 609 but compare you know the
volumes here 36 6 that's nothing it just
gets lifted almost immediately it trades
you know 314 334 41 that's two
imbalances right there and you form
another bar I'm not expecting the way
this bar is shaped up with a thin volume
on this side you know the imbalance is
up here the heaviest volume in the bar
then on the bid side is on the bottom
you know it's just telling me there's
their support of buying in here right
here this 609 and you got the aggressive
buying going on on the way back up
that's what I love and look at that look
how it moved from 2780 straight up
really quick all the way up to here you
got a ratio of indicating price
rejection and what happens is you come
off start coming off you got a buy here
but look then you in the sense of you
know price rejection here and it's a
pullback ok market you know just shot up
you got a pull back at this point you
don't know ok is this is this the
temporary is it gonna go up there were
signs of price rejection you know I'd be
willing to take that shot that you know
maybe this is a little bit of a pullback
and
you know the profit-taking coming in
there we go up but it starts coming back
down you got nice and balanced here 1300
then here you got bearish ratio
indicating price rejection then look at
this you got the bearish ratio racial
bonds low indicating price resistance
here and you got this stacked imbalance
here I know what happens is you sell-off
but though is then it starts coming
right back up you got the bullish ratio
you got the nice imbalance twelve
hundred nine hundred eight hundred nine
hundred you know when a market is
selling off what you're looking for are
the imbalances look at the imbalances
you see selling a balance down and
balance on the balance down a balance
you know you're already getting the
clues in here after you hit the swing
high with the bearish ratio with the
imbalances over the next two bars then
you get another imbalance here in the
fifth bar and you sell off even before
you got this bearish ratio then you
start coming up okay you don't know you
don't know hey are we going lower I mean
this is a very bearish bar this is this
is a very bearish bar but it sort of
comes down in here you got the strong
positive Delta 2000 you haven't had that
strong in Delta since you know it's just
before that high so yeah I know you yeah
so what happens right imagine what's
going on in the market market is sold
off okay strong selling no positive
deltas you got a bar here with positive
Delta does that mean this move is over
not necessarily but that's a sign
potentially that maybe this market could
be this move moved down can be close to
over so what you're gonna do is you you
don't take it because you got one bar
with positive Delta they don't say oh
hey we got bar a positive Delta I gotta
buy no you wait for some more signs okay
because especially this bar very bearish
strong negative Delta imbalances stacked
imbalance you know bearish ratio but you
know this bar would look a lot better if
it appeared much higher on this move the
last thing I would say take things in
context alright if you want to get short
where do you want to get sure you wanna
get short after the markets rallied
rather than after the markets sold off
you know those are gonna be the better
trades but you know whatever even though
I just talked about this by right here
this was interesting because we had RAL
right from 2770 just after the cash
opened down here right 27 70 but look we
got to this area in here okay and
basically we're going sideways in this
area right in here from 9 o'clock
basically until 9:30 just basically
going sideways back and forth then
you're getting some signs of the
aggressive buying coming in there then
you shot up another five points okay so
anyway back here you know I'm not
convinced that this is going to be a
swing low yet just because I got deposit
Delta it's encouraging it's a nice
strong positive Delta next bar it's a
positive Delta it's a little it's a
thousand one 165 it's you know half of
what it is in the previous bar but it's
still strong it's over a thousand on a
forming JSONP is is considered strong in
my book okay but you know I'd love it if
it was you know 2,000 but you know it's
still strong a thousand okay it's not
weak it's not like 300 but you know it's
it's it's decent it's still it's still
strong then you look at this you got the
bullish ratio indicating price rejection
then boom you get imbalanced 1200
imbalance 900 okay so this this bit of a
structure here to me is very very nice
to see what I like this is you gotten
strong negative Delta weaker Delta a
positive Delta positive Delta positive
Delta because what's going on you get
the big push down big last big push of
selling coming right in this bar hits
here a little bit more it's not done yet
then boom the buying comes in so what
you're going to look for is you're gonna
look for signs of aggressive buying
signs of price rejection you got the
aggressive buying here 800 1200 900 now
you're seeing signs of price rejection
here you still got the positive Delta
which is good and as well as encouraging
just go sideways next bar down you know
if you're buying it here you think it's
like what happened and mark is sold
off another point but you know it's not
the end of the world you know that oh my
gosh you know the market just I bought
it here at 81 and three quarters all son
were trading you know eighty and three
quarters okay where are you going to be
placing your stop right you mean looking
at these pointed controls this should be
resistance remember if this is going to
be your swing low look for these pointed
controls so old what happens this is
your swing low point of control came
right down to this level point of
control one tick above this bar you know
it's it's arranged bar so it's not quite
there but the next bar boom where'd it
go it came right down there okay look at
this point control came right here so
you should be convinced already there
over these five bars just that structure
I just explained for the last few
minutes is very bullish and look so if
you're buying it even here at 81 and a
half you know what to do it comes all
the way up here to you know 83 and a
half that's a quick two points in thirty
minutes now you know again you know sort
of going back to what I was talking
about where if if you're convinced of a
market move you really shouldn't be
pulling back beyond the point of
controls like here all right this is the
bar I said no this was a great buying
bar point of control right here we're
above it point of control still above it
point of control still above it point of
control we come back down yeah yet one
tick through okay point of control
you're still above it point of control
still above it you know on this move
down take a look at this point of
control right here where you do get
within one tick of it here's the point
of control still below it here it comes
up but then look at this bar you're
still below the point of control higher
this bar still below that point of
control this bar point of control is
where you came right back to this bar
side-by-side opponent controls yeah two
ticks through okay it's a doji bar but
look this bar still point control
underneath so I said you don't watch
those pointed controls they are very
very very very telling now this one here
at 12 this was very interesting I
remember looking at this and I was
talking to somebody at the time and I
said this is very bullish you know
someone says well it's confusing you
know one should take out the other well
what's happening you kind of just
meandering here going sideways bah bah
you know not much no you straight down
you trade up start coming down you got
the bearish ratio
you've got the stacks selling a balance
but look how you come out of the stacks
on the balance what
riten after you got the stacks on
imbalance you've got a stack buying a
balance right where you had this tax
sell on a balance and you know it's
always a bad sign when you have a stack
selling the balance and you got a green
bar right through it it's also a bad
sign when you got a stacks on the
balance and you got stack mine imbalance
going the opposite direction but what
you should be watching for is signs that
know there's more aggressive buying
coming in I mean once you once the
stacks on imbalance is taken out I'm
beyond the stacks on balance I'm not
even thinking about it anymore
instead I'm focused on the aggressive
buying so I got the stack selling the
balance okay well it comes right back
with stack buying balance so at this
point I'm beyond this I'm not still
stuck on this now I know so there's some
traders will get short on the stacks on
a balance and then because they're in a
position mentally they'll think I'm just
gonna wait and see even though they got
a very bullish shine right here all
right they're not doing what they should
do and get out they think well I'm in
this trade you know this is the
difference that separates traders that
are sort of breakeven or losing money
for traders that are consistently
successful is consistently successful
successful traders will understand that
when they're wrong you know their whole
reason for being in a trade is gone
get out don't just stay in there hoping
that's gonna come back down right so you
got the stacks on a balance when it
comes right back you've got bullish
signs in here if you don't recognize
that you should not be short at this
point you're going to get killed and you
know maybe not in one trade but it's
just gonna eat away overall the trades
over time that you take that you don't
get out of and so what happens is you
get market starts coming up buying
imbalances here buying imbalance buying
a balance got bearish ratio indicating
price rejection so instead of focusing
on the stacks selling a balance now you
should be focusing on the stack buying a
balance and what happens boom boom boom
if you don't recognize this already you
have a stack buying imbalance again you
know some people are still focused on
the stacks on the balance focus on the
stack buying a balance it's holding
right it's holding you came back down in
there it's holding that support and look
up up up they get up here multiple
imbalances in this bar
you start coming off come back up here
to this same level you got a price where
you sign a price rejection now the sign
of price rejection is coming at an area
where earlier you had you had multiple
imbalances not stacked in balance you
got one two three but you got this one
842 in there that's why we put this box
around it to highlight that hey you have
multiple imbalances in the bar it's
still just as important as a stack the
imbalance and it comes off comes back up
here signs the price rejection where you
were earlier so you imagine you're
coming back up to an area where you had
aggressive selling you sort of come back
up into that area
you still got some aggressive selling
you don't have aggressive buying instead
you got price rejection and what happens
boom from 1406 over the next ten minutes
you sell off from 85 and a half down to
eighty two and a half so that those were
some some of the nice trades in the S&P
s now let me just see the other chart
real quick okay so this is the SNR
levels for yesterday in the SN pieces to
the four range I'm putting it on this
this chart this is a bar chart just so
it's a little bit easier to to talk
about so since basically well it goes in
7 a.m. 8 and chiron 8 a.m. okay so just
go through the cache open here cache
open is 8:30
you got a buy signal here just around
8:30 3:00 look at that what's that price
27 you know you're buying it here 72
shoot straight up makes new highs still
got supported buying coming in just off
the highs now why is that important it's
because that's telling you that this
move is pretty strong you imagine you're
making new highs and you got supported
by and coming in
chances are you gonna make new highs and
you do you get all the way up to 80 you
got a cell here that fails it breaks
down still seeing some strong buying
coming in you know another point and a
half point and 3/4 then you start coming
off you you get the support of buying
around the same area that you had it
before however you know it just got
overrun here and you know you dip down
then you got some more supportive buying
it's still look at this it's still
around that same area so you know it's
one thing to how to say it you know so
imagine here can you see
these blue areas right so I know that
this blue in these blue areas I'm
expecting supportive buying
okay so what happens is you trade below
we start coming up you see supported
buying you still got that one bar with
some resistance selling still got
support of buying and it's just hanging
around here still hanging around here
you know you talk about having a low
risk trade right if I know I got one two
three four areas in here with supported
buying since you know nine forty up to
eleven forty you know I'm pretty
confident that you know if I can get
long somewhere here eighty to you know
stop down here at eighty one that you
know Papa's possibly we can trade higher
even make new highs I mean now I know
that I may run into resistance selling
and I knew here but look where's it
trade back down to trades back down to
ad two again so I know just by looking
left all right
I shouldn't say looking left right
looking left okay this area in here
between is around eighty two and a half
down to eighty one and a half somewhere
in here let me see my drawing tools
basically from you know anywhere between
this line and say
anyway not-not-not as far as that but
she doesn't there we go
you know somewhere in this area all
right if I know we start coming back
like here we see we traded down through
it but then we start coming back in what
I'm looking for is this buying that was
here earlier is it present in here and
it is you see it here you see it in this
bar alright you don't necessarily see it
in here
maybe it's seen a little bit mixed in
really the volumes are just starting to
peter out a little bit but you know this
is what you call a little restraint you
know you've got all this aggressive
buying in these areas in here that you
put your bid in here eighty to call it
right in the middle or is your stop just
below it eighty one you know one point
and if you're buying it here you know
eighty two boom you know up to eighty
four boom you buy it again
eighty two we're up to eighty five you
know even here you got in another buy
signal in there you know now this area
that was here so you got buy signal here
buy signal there sure you do run into
resistance you can make the argument
that there's resistance here maybe not
want to take any trades this one again
you know it's already just right ahead
of cash close that's 250 in the
afternoon you know it's just gonna be a
little bit fall til it the way the
market was running today it's just gonna
be a little volatile there so but you
know that that's how you trade support
and resistance levels it's not you know
honestly the way people draw a support
resistance levels is they'll say well
the market hit this area up and you know
hit this area here hit this high or even
here the hit this high now this is this
is what you call resistance becoming
support so just draw this here so you
got a resistance level here based on the
order flow all right these are order
flow based resistance levels now you
broke through it you made new highs okay
come off I knew I had a resistance level
now resistance once you violate it start
trading higher is gonna become your
support and what happens we right we
sell off from this high up here was 85
and three-quarters all the way back down
in a 80 79 in three quarters well five
point move
and now let's become your support area
and you rally back up to that high but
again you know this is now something you
just got to you know get used to and an
understanding trading where failed
support or failed resistance become the
opposite you know failed support becomes
resistance failed resistance becomes
support ok so just real quick I'll go
over the buns this video is getting a
little bit longer than I imagined but I
won't talk about the buns buns is a
great contract for a number of reasons
one you know it's it's the tick size is
easy easy it's it's 10 euros a tick and
it moves nicely its moves in you know
it's decimal I so it moves from like you
know 160 140 to 160 141 you know where
are our bonds move in 30 seconds but and
and the other nice thing is it's got a
long trading day basically it opens at
1:00 a.m. she cago time and cash closes
around 10 and then it trades you know
after the cash closes I forgot what time
it's like till 3:00 I believe I think
it's 3:00 3:00 p.m. you know usually
after about 11:00 I'm done looking at it
but you get some beautiful moves you
know this is the SNR levels indicator
okay look at this right after the open a
sell comes down here to a buy come back
up here it's around the same area but
this one fails and what I was just
talking about resistance become support
you can see how if you draw this a zone
out its above here she'll coming in here
now it's your support level rallies back
up you guys sell here it doesn't really
work out in the I sell here nice little
move down 10 ticks coming in this is I'm
gonna close to show you a bunch of days
here same thing here you got a support
level that's holding then what happens
once it breaks it becomes your
resistance area then January 9th it's
Tuesday
don't get a signal here till late then
you got a couple sell signals this one
failed then you got one too you know
you're talking you know training around
the 162 even area look at this move
won't straight down here very quick over
the next two hours from 162 down to you
know the 160 165 area
this by first one fails second one fails
as well got a support area it holds for
a while you get a little bit of a move
up not the most spectacular move cache
is closed here then you just sort of go
sideways you got a couple buys here but
the market just you know it goes higher
but mostly sideways the next day the
tenth couple sells here and get a little
bit of a move down sell here a little
small move in the sell here a little
small move this by this sell fails the
sell fails then you get this beautiful
one again one sixty one thirty two
thirty around there 160 130 132 boom
right down to 160 105 we get the buy
signal how you covering it down here
this buy signal fails eventually it goes
up this one fails then you got this nice
one here around the 160 110 area back up
to the 160 123 area this sell look at
this I started talking about with order
flow I mean people say well yeah you had
some resistance you know you had some
highs here but actually if you're
looking at a chart most people withdraw
their their resistance level here just
above this area because if you're
looking on a candlestick they'll draw it
on the body the upper end of the body
some people even go buy the wicks which
I don't think you should anyway go buy
the wicks we should be going from the
high here but it's just we only trade up
just below it but based on the order
flow you know it's coming in in here so
you know you could be sitting here you
sell this here but you know we sell-off
rally back up you should be up in here
with sell orders around the 25 area all
right so what happens we come back up
here to 25 and then when you sell off
back down to you know the 160 105 area
come back up here the sell fails then
boom you got another nice sell here one
sixty one twenty back down though you
know 160 105 again you got to buy in
here
161 Oh 508 thereabouts and you know what
happens is your rally back up look at
this this move from 160 108 look at this
from 38 straight back up you gotta sell
here yeah oh this is the next day
actually this is the reopen so we closed
so we went from 116 you know at 10
o'clock here just straight up the rest
of the day I mean
nothing else words Kanaks describe it
now that's what you want as a traitor
you don't want to be getting in and out
if you can catch the trend you know
that's what trading is about catching
the trend so on the 11th this is
Thursday now small move right after the
open nothing big and this one nothing
then here this zone again all right this
is I talk about it okay look I can draw
this out like if I extend this I wish my
drawing tools yeah I could do the hot
key but I've learned that sometimes I do
the hockey and I screw it up and I
delete it I delete more stuff that I
need okay so look at this okay this is
understandings resistance areas now what
problem let's say the problem but you
know we're a lot of people go wrong on
understanding resistance is what the do
is okay hey I've got a high here and
they'll wait to come back okay and we've
touched it back here again so now I got
a double top so now I got resistance and
then they're getting short you know in
here somewhere
what order flow allows you to do is hey
it tells you hey you've got resistance
in here in the order flow in the volume
in what's trading it's happening in real
time so when you're looking at this
chart here okay hey I know I know I got
a I got a resistance level here one
sixty one fifty three two you know 55 56
okay let's just wait you know I've
thrown some offers up in here just you
know literate with some offers that if
we come back up there we'll see if it's
gonna hold just like you would do here
you're throwing some offers here you're
throw-in something off this one you
throw some offers here right this one it
just stops you out period I mean that's
what happens you know in trading now you
know in trading there you're gonna have
trades that don't work out you're gonna
have trades that work out this one
didn't work out but that's about
managing your risk you put your limits
in here it immediately stops you out
okay it's not you look for the next
trade you get back up and you look for
the trade so here you get it you get you
know you get short already you know here
you know I don't know if you get filled
I mean you really should be looking at
55 you know
you got the uptick here 253 then you
sell off okay you got a buy here okay I
got a buy signal where you know so you
get any long so if you're short off this
you're covering it down here and now
you're long well what's your target well
your target is your resistance level you
know you got a target up in here so how
you're gonna trade it is you you have
offers up in here to get short to cover
this long and to get short don't expect
it to blow right through there because
you're long and keep going up no you
have to think all right you have to look
for the resistance area so you sell off
you come down here you got a buy signal
now you should already be having orders
in here for the for the move back up
regardless of having this buy signal you
should still be thinking of getting
short in here because what can happen is
we can just be selling you know
range-bound
you don't know what's gonna happen next
you say you have to sort of approach it
that way so what do you do is you have
offers in here get short now you get
short and to cover your long from
earlier okay you can probably buy some
back in here so you're short you think
one you could cover back some here as
well you don't have to necessarily cover
everything just as you know when you're
long in here you know you might want to
have one or two for you know if you're
gonna break through there and you so you
could ride the trend longer but here you
know what happens let me look at this
probably not explaining it best but if
you were to draw this out you know right
now this market is just showing you this
is what a range bond market looks like
you resistance to support trade from
resistance down to support back up to
resistance back down to support now I'm
not saying that you would have held it
you know held this short or held this
short and count this massive move down
no honestly most traders would be
trading you know from short to long
short maybe back long again but then
they're holding it here you know you
mean there's absolutely no reason to
think that oh you know I'm gonna hold it
and we're gonna break down to new lows
know at this point not but you know what
you have your support here you know can
you make the arguments gonna become
resistance
the fact that you just sort of hanging
around here I don't know you mean I know
people that would like to trade the
breakouts and if you trade the breakout
and you could have caught this move this
buy failed here these buys also failed
but again look at this just sort of go
go through it again exactly what I was
just talking about more support later
becomes resistance right these two
buyers here
so you know we broke down it broke down
now I'm looking at senator this means
support I'm looking forward to be
resistance so you put some offers in
here now if we come back maybe you catch
that move back down and you do from you
know this is 160 68 69 oh we don't tell
you know 160 39 that's 30 points it
doesn't look like much around this you
know it's because this is a big move
down but there's 30 points right there
30 ticks you know then you got some
small moves here some small bounces this
one fails this one fails but again I
can't stress this enough failed
resistance becomes your support come
down in here you're buying it all right
so then it comes to the 12th which is
Friday and again it's just given some
nice signals here this buy fails the
sell it kind of mixing you got a nice
sell here a nice buy here the sell fails
the sell works this buy works this sell
works this by its kind of mix nothing
then later in the day look at this you
got a nice little sell here
you got these this big clump in here a
resistance selling which fails and
becomes your support area this
resistance selling doesn't work this now
look at this
supportive buying here and if you
include this other one is this area in
here so you have this supportive buying
and you got this sign of support of
buying this resistance selling or to me
it's already failed so I'm not really
looking at this as resistance but
I know I've got support here support
here you know the the high of this bar
to the low of this block high of this
block to the low of this block is this
area and what happens so even if you're
just trading you know it in here this
block out here yeah you got some bids in
here I mean look at that 160 you know
anywhere between 160 35 and 160 31 in
here if you had it the foresight to put
some limit orders in that boom 30 over
the next few minutes this is a 1-minute
chart by the way you're talking boom
boom boom 30 ticks right away so that's
the SNR levels on the bones and on the
e-mini sits this video is a little bit
longer than I imagined but you know I'm
just trying to show you how to trade
with this stuff you know on how to use
order flow again if you're not convinced
on order flows you could buy the SNR
levels separately but I think you know
when you're using it with order flow it
just makes your trading a heck of a lot
easier I just showed it to you on a bar
chart by in the next video I'll show it
to you on a footprint chart and you know
it's just a great tool it's great tool
to add to your trading you know I'm not
saying you have to become an order flows
trader but you know where you got to
understand every single nuance of order
flow because there's a lot to understand
with order flow but honestly you got to
take the first step eventually and
figure out where you want to be in your
trading next week next year and three
years down the line you know the great
athletes great players
I love reading biographies and about you
know great athletes and what they do to
become better it's not like you get to a
certain level and that's it like okay
I've made it to the NBA that's it I'm
happy I'm not gonna work hard anymore no
it's they get to the NBA they got to
work harder to keep working at it
and the same things in training right
every year Michael Jordan would add
something new to his what do you want I
don't know what to call it his
repertoire so to speak you know early on
in in his career would be all Michael
Jordan does his dunk well you know if
you won't know how he was able to last
so long he had to change his game he had
to adapt and learn
new things you know also you know after
a few years of just slamming you know
just dunking all the time you know he
acquired a jump shot and then he
acquired a three-point shot you know
people who say oh he's only offensive
player doesn't play defense you know guy
how many years did he win the offense of
the Defensive Player of the Year award
you know you don't you don't think of
Michael Jordan necessarily I mean most
people think of Michael Jordan is just
you know the slam dunk King but you know
he's also a great defensive player I
mean that's how he was able to help the
Bulls win all those championships is by
every year adding something new to his
game and that's what you should be
thinking of doing as a traitor you know
add something new to your training you
know if you're already successful great
but there's nothing stopping you from
you know trying to get better at it and
more successful so thanks everyone and
have a great day and now I'm sort of
getting back in the swing of creating
videos I hope to sort of get them out to
you on a fairly regular basis now so
thanks everyone that have emailed me I'm
trying to get through the EULA psychic
kind of I think of changing my email
address is so much spam I think I get my
my cat order phones that email I get a
probably about 90% spam on that yeah I'm
not talking about like I get 20 emails a
day and eighteen of them are spam I know
I get like hundreds of emails a day and
you know there's about 20 of them that
are business-related the rest is just
all junk mail so I also if I do change
it all the customers out there will get
my new email address and I'm trying to
create some other new things so more
interaction like a message board where I
could post charts so you know people who
come in and look at the charts and make
their comments or I'll give my thoughts
on the charts and you know it's open to
discussions so thanks everyone okay I
got some big things planned for this
year and I'll keep you posted so thanks
and if you haven't subscribe to the
channel please do bye bye